هذه قصه رحمه واجبه حكايه ناجين من البشر
ينتظرون ناجينا من غير البشر
السيده بيرجول خائفه تنتظر انقاذ روح
عالقه تحت انقاذ الحظيره
اليوم توجهت لاطعامها اعتقدت انها قد ماتت
اخاطر بحياتي يوميا للوصول اليها
بعد انهيار المكان بالكامل
على مدى 11 يوما كانت السيده بيرجيل تشق
طريقها تحت الانقاض لتصل اليها
وبينما يستمرون في ازاله الركام يتمكن
فريق بيطري من حفر نفق وراء المبنى
لا تزال حيه
لم تاكل شيئا اليوم فقد شربت الماء اعتقدت
انها ماتت الان ابلغوني انها حيه
ضمن خطط الاستجابه للكارثه تنتشر فرق
مختصه بانقاذ الحيوانات المنزليه في مناطق
الزلزال
انقذنا حتى اليوم بين 50 الى 60 حيوانا
ارسلناها الى اضنه للعلاج في مستشفى بيطري
بعد ذلك نعيدهم الى اصحابهم نحن جاهزون
عندما نتلقى اي اتصال من عائله نتوجه
للموقع ونحاول المساعده
الثروه الحيوانيه مساله مهمه يقولون لنا
لدعم معيشه العائلات في ارياف المحافظات
المنكوبه والتي تعتمد على الزراعه والثروه
الحيوانيه في معيشتها
الا ان العمل لا يقتصر على انقاذ موارد
الحياه فالفرق الميدانيه تعمل على قاعده
انقاذ كل حياه تحت الانقاض
نعود الى بيرجان سحبت من تحت الانقاض
اسال الله ان يرضى عن فرق الانقاض
تنتهي قصتنا بخبر مفرح ليستمر الامل في
انتشار مزيد من الناجين سلام خضر الجزيره